yes let's talk about this podcast so who
called who like whose idea was this
first
uh well i was approached um with the
idea
and i instantly emailed melinda we
hadn't spoken or seen each other in like
five years or something
but um yeah so i emailed her and i was
like hey
wanna do a podcast like it was a very
simple email i know mindy you've talked
about it but um that's how we got the
ball rolling
right it was um mindy it's bilson it's
like hmm
i think i know that name i know this is
random but
but then of course not knowing much
about the podcast world i researched it
and quite a few have come out of this
pandemic
and just feels really really such a
great opportunity to
walk down memory lane and reconnect with
so many people
and put some smiles on people's faces
yeah
another thing like not that this is
youtube but it seems like a lot of
actors used to be kind of hesitant to
talk about like the big roles in their
career just
you know they want to move on but it
really seems like like the past year
we've seen all these reunions happen and
people willing to talk about their you
know some of the big roles that they've
had in their career
like could you have seen yourself doing
this three years ago or was the past
year like kind of get you in nostalgic
mood melinda if you want to start
you know i think nostalgia is just
super super prevalent right now yeah
and and doing this podcast of course i
do some research of
once again i'm the researcher and um
you know i'm i think there's a lot of
people that are understanding that
you know even before the pandemic
you know i love being an actor and i
love being on set but sometimes those
those jobs can take us away from our
families they can be 20-hour days
and um it just feels like so many people
alec baldwin
or the i just found out there's an
entourage um podcast
um so many people are doing shows
because we get to do it from the comfort
of our home i was in the shower
45 minutes ago now i'm talking to you
so but revisiting the show honestly
i've always loved the subject of the oc
i love talking about it i love
dissecting
how it came about how much fun it was
what happened
um should it have gone on should it have
you know ended the way it did
all of those things are subjects that i
love talking about
and so i would have i would have done
this three years ago for sure but
but i think it's um it's very popular
right now so
the timing couldn't be perfect yeah
really chill do you think
yeah i mean i'm such a fan of the show i
always have been
i love talking about it and like melinda
said i mean
there's such such a need for nostalgia
now and like
remembering how things were you know
before everything
you know happened in the world and i
just
i'm a fan of it it's just a lot of fun
and it's something fun to do
and to be able to do it from home and i
have a six-year-old daughter and
we were just home and she just started
school again but
it was like a no-brainer you know
especially doing it with melinda and
being able to revisit it and all these
fun memories
things we've never talked about before
just given the opportunity to have fun
and talk about it
yeah did you check out like any other
ones that are going on right now like
you guys are doing like
episode by episode which is what the
office leaders are doing like jenna
fisher and angel kinsey of course like
jenny garth
and tory spelling are doing the 90210
did you check out other what other tv
shows are doing or other actors from tv
shows doing
rachel yeah well i i didn't at first
because i didn't really want to get in
my head
and compare it but as we got closer i
listened to the pilot episode of the
office ladies
and i loved it and i was like oh okay
this is fun and they're just talking and
they're friends and
so that kind of gave me a little bit
more of a boost of like okay you can do
this
um this sounds fun but yeah and mindy's
much more of a research
researcher as she said so she definitely
did more than i did but
now that we're doing it i am listening
to more um and i
like zach braff and donald faison have
theirs for scrubs and
and it's just fun to listen to all of
them yeah
yeah melinda like you've i know you've
released two have you guys taped any
more than that at this point
yes i think we're about
give or take about a dozen oh wow okay
yeah yeah so what has surprised you
about
like we are starting revisiting these uh
episodes
like do you remember everything that
happened
rachel no
it turns out i have a terrible memory
um so we'll be revisiting an episode and
talking about it and i will have
no idea what happened and i'm like what
you know all these spoiler alerts and
everything and i even if i'm in the
scene or storyline i have no clue
so for me i'm literally watching it as
an audience member
basically for the first time and i'm
learning a lot
to be fair there are moments
where i have been watching and thought
oh i forgot about that but of course i
remember it now but
um i think i watched the show a little
bit more in the past
15 years more than um probably rachel
did
because i have a daughter who's 21 and
and um
honestly i would break it out for
whoever i was um who might be interested
because i had a dvd set and i was like
hey you want to check it out let's check
it out
a little wine may have been involved but
that's it
yeah exactly yeah for each one of you
like is there an episode that you're
nervous or very excited about to revisit
rachel do you want to start
yeah i think mindy and i both feel
nervous about the episode where marissa
dies like we're very
hesitant to revisit that and talk about
it and relive it
um because it was a hard thing you know
personally and
professionally on the show so we're both
a little hesitant with that one
um i mean i know i'm talking for you
mindy but we've talked about it now
um yeah and uh
excited i'm honestly i like to see the
seth and summer dynamic i like
i actually wanted to see julie cooper's
whole journey
because there's so much she does and
that we've been talking about so i'm
really excited to see certain things
that
uh melinda had to do
we have a lot of content coming up um
there will be no lack of content or
comments or um
revelations right i know there's a lot
of actors that don't like watching
themselves how are you guys with
watching yourself and when they'll start
with you i gotta tell you i
i love watching the show because i'm
looking at this you know through a new
set of eyes as a fan
and um sorry my puppy wants to wants to
be cut here
and what i'm having trouble doing is
watching us on the podcast because
i think i'm used to seeing myself as a
character and
not as mindy you know
but no i love watching the show yeah
where were you rachel how you were
watching yourself oh
um well it's a little weird because this
is 18 years ago so i'm watching a
different person so i can remove myself
a little bit and i'm like oh my gosh
this is so crazy
uh i mean i i kind of am like i don't
take anything too seriously so i can sit
through it
there might be times where i have to
like turn my head but that's right
i know you're gonna have like guests on
like have you talked to other cast
members
that join like misha and ben and adam
we we do have cast members coming on
obviously we haven't uh
done them all yet but we what have we
said mindy that we can say
well we're trying to have a little bit
of a surprise factor
right um but yes peter gallagher is
coming up next
um that'll be interesting because that
was our first one
so it's a fun conversation um tate
donovan
and um and some of them were going to
leave as a surprise but by the end
of the 92 episodes let's hope that every
single cast member has stopped by
that's ambitious yeah that's a good
that's a good plan to have like i know
you guys said you hadn't really talked a
few years like have you guys kept in
touch with various
cast members yeah i am
kelly rowan and i are very good friends
in fact when i was in
um toronto she was living there and
peter was doing a series there so we
would all get together
that was um around 2012 2013
but um yeah i mean from time to time
it might be once every couple years but
um we do stay in contact and there are a
few that i haven't stayed in contact and
i
hope to reconnect with yeah where were
you rachel
yeah well uh josh schwartz the creator
of the show is basically
my brother we're very close um but other
than that
cast wise you know i hadn't seen melinda
in five years but it's like no time has
gone by that's the whole thing with all
of us you know i ran into adam brody
on an airplane a couple years ago and
again it was like hey
you know super fun and familiar um but i
would love to see everybody again it's
really fun having people come on and
reconnecting
and it's just been a blast yeah i know
you've been teasing like you might have
celeb fans on i know you're not gonna
tell me any names yeah can you like
tease anyone or like what's gonna happen
here
what's gonna happen here we have yeah
we're having some fun
people that were fans of the show i mean
we're still collecting
the list so to speak but there's also
some fun
people that have their own podcasts uh
things like that
and doing some crossovers so there's
lots to look forward to yeah that's a
cool
thing that's good yeah rachel i think we
should put it out there that if
if any of you super fans um are
listening
um reach out to cast media and you just
might get on the show
cool too
[Laughter]
so melinda watching these old episodes
what do you miss most about
shooting the show um
i love that it was in los angeles you
know so that
a lot of i mean i love working on any
location but it was really
lovely to be able to um have my daughter
at school
drive to manhattan beach i don't miss
the traffic but
um i really feel like
every day that i got to go to work on
the oc it literally was like going to
musical theater camp because that's what
i did when i was a teenager and
i loved doing it um so
every day was an opportunity to take
risks to laugh to hang out with
with the cast the crew um all of our
dogs on set
um it was really a fun set and those are
my memories
yeah what were you rachel yeah uh
everything about the memories of the
show right
yeah yeah yeah yeah sure yeah what do
you miss actually what do i miss
now you're watching the old episode yeah
yeah sorry
um yeah no shooting in la is huge you
know we don't get to do that often
although i have shot in canada and loved
it just like mindy
i have to say um but it was just
nice having a family and and going to
the same place every day with the same
people and enjoying it and i was really
lucky to
love everyone i worked with and it's
such a fond memory
personally and professionally and those
years are pretty informative you know i
was 21 to
25. so yeah it was quite the ride
sorry no go ahead now i just had a
conversation with cindy rachel our
makeup artist
and um she had a photo album of the show
of all things and she told me to this
day that show
is her favorite show and she's been
doing this for you know 20 something
years
so there's a lot of memories and we'll
have her on but there's
everybody um so many people have such
fond memories and it was a start
for a lot of people whether it was guest
stars or the editors we're finding out
all of these great tidbits that we're
sharing with the audience wow
yeah that's awesome i know you're
probably sick of this question but since
you are revisiting the show
like any chance of like a revival like
can you see any way of like
revisiting that world with certain
characters rachel
well you know this obviously comes up a
lot right
now and you know i'm always like hey if
josh warts and stephanie savage can
figure it out i'm there um
i think there are things that you could
do with the show if the show ended and
there were babies born that
would be in high school now which is
insane um
but i don't know it's it's like this
weird thing like do you want to touch
something
that kind of was all wrapped up pretty
nicely and and
you know lives in people's memories and
whatnot as is
it it's a tough thing to kind of yeah
decide
but yeah you know what do you think
melinda
well yes to all of that um i think
there's
of course you can do a revival um of
course there are stories
to explore and i have my own fan fiction
about what julie's doing she's
pretty much ruling the world with
bullets um billionaire money
um and uh but
but there are a lot of people that we've
talked to who have said exactly what
rachel said don't touch it
let's just talk about it so um
i would be on board if something were to
happen but um
for for right now we're just reminiscing
and and talking about it
yeah i think that's perfect i think it's
such a great idea yeah so
congratulations on this guys it's such a
fun idea and i can't wait to hear more
of it